hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and both the one
piece manga and film red have just given
us some major reveals about shanks buggy
and their secret origins secret origins
that are directly connected to the
infamous god valley incident shanks is
practically confirmed to be a celestial
dragon buggy could be the biological son
of rox d zebek and roger knew everything
because it was all a part of his master
plan so let's get into it before we
start quick warning that there have been
a bunch of scammers in the comments
claiming to be anime uproar and offering
like giveaways through telegram and
other apps we do not use telegram this
is not us this is a scam and we will
never do a giveaway without mentioning
it in the video itself so please be
careful if you see someone in the
comments talking about a giveaway and
you didn't hear it in the video please
ignore it we try to ban these scammers
from the channel as much as we can but
unfortunately they're bots and they keep
popping up if you are not a bot or
scammer please leave a like and comment
on this video to help us out with that
youtube algorithm and of course don't
forget to hit that subscribe button
while you're here it means a lot finally
this video will contain one piece manga
spoilers and spoilers for film red so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned for a very long time the
entire one piece fan base has been
wondering how shanks and buggy ended up
on goldie rogers crew at such a young
age it certainly isn't common for a
powerful pirate crew to have numerous
pre-teen children as its members and
this is something that shanks himself
explained to luffy way back in chapter 1
young children don't belong on a pirate
ship and yet ironically even as young
children shanks and buggy were on the
crew of the most infamous pirate in
modern history and since we know that
both of these children would one day
grow up to be emperors of the sea it
really makes you wonder what their true
origins are and how the two of them
ended up on roger's ship
for many years fans have speculated that
it could all be connected to the
mysterious god valley incident which
took place when both shanks and buggy
would be about one-year-old children
believe it or not film red actually
confirms this long speculated connection
a free volume containing interesting
facts about one piece was distributed to
people who attended the film red
screenings in japan and this volume
revealed that 38 years ago roger found a
one-year-old shanks inside a treasure
chest on god valley yes you heard that
right shanks was found on god valley the
same place where the epic battle between
the rox pirates and the roger pirates
and the marines took place so what was
the god valley incident 44 years ago rox
d zebek formed an unbelievably stacked
crew on the pirate island of hachinosu
as all of us already know this crew
included a young whitebeard kaido big
mom shiki silverax wang ji and captain
john among others but rox wasn't just
your average pirate he wasn't interested
in becoming the pirate king he openly
declared war against the world
government and he vowed to become the
king of the whole world the rox pirates
waged war against the world government
for six years and then 38 years ago rox
and his crew attacked a mysterious
island called god valley according to
sengoku multiple celestial dragons and
their slaves were present on god valley
at the time of the attack the world
government was extremely committed to
saving these celestial dragons and to
defeating the rox pirates and so they
dispatched a powerful force of marines
led by vice admiral garp to god valley
and if that wasn't enough the world
government actually teamed up with one
of their mortal enemies goldie roger and
the roger pirates in order to defeat the
rox pirates together garp and roger were
the ones who led the battle against
rocks and according to the information
that sengoku gave us in the end roger
and garp won rox was killed the rock's
pirates were disbanded and from that day
forward garp became known as the hero of
the marines in film red the goro say
state that shanks is actually a member
of the figureland family and who is the
figureland family well we don't know but
this family is clearly well known to the
gorosei the gorosei expressed concern
that utta a major character from the
movie is shanks's adoptive daughter the
reason why they're concerned is because
being shanks's daughter also makes her a
member of the figureland family this
implies that shanks's full name is
shanks figureland and when we combine
the fact that the gorosei are clearly
aware of this family and that the
importance of this family name concerns
them with the fact that baby shanks was
found by roger on god valley where
celestial dragons were confirmed to be
present at the time it seems almost
certain that shanks is a member of a
prominent family of celestial dragons
whose surname is figure land
roger found shanks inside a treasure
chest at some point during his battle
against rocks on god valley now shanks
might have been hidden by his parents
inside that treasure chest in order to
escape being killed by rocks or rox
might have kidnapped him and placed him
inside that treasure chest because he
considered the baby just another part of
his loot but either way in the end the
baby ended up in roger's hands for
whatever reason roger couldn't return
the baby to its parents so he decided to
raise shanks aboard his own ship it's
possible that shanks's real parents were
killed and so roger had no way to return
the baby or it's possible that if roger
had tried to return shanks to the world
government they would have accused him
of kidnapping the baby which would
result in an all-out war between roger
and the world government because there
is no greater crime than kidnapping a
celestial dragon's baby whatever the
reason roger decided to keep shanks and
this single decision was the catalyst
for the entire one piece story just
think about it if shanks hadn't been a
pirate who came to fuja village all
those years ago luffy may never have set
out on his pirate adventure and the one
piece story as we know it could not
exist full disclosure i haven't had the
opportunity to actually watch film red
because it is currently only airing in
japan but a huge shout out to artur
library of ahara for sharing these
insane reveals about shanks on his
youtube channel artur saw the movie and
made a video that provides a ton of
great information about what actually
happens in film red and how much of it
may or may not be canon so definitely
check that out i will link artur's video
down in the description now of course
many fans will be wondering just how
much of film red is actually canonical
to the manga the information about baby
shanks being found by roger on god
valley is almost certainly canon because
it appears in that free volume i
mentioned earlier this volume was
officially written by aichiro oda and is
separate from the plot of the movie so
it can be considered canon even if the
movie itself is not in terms of the
events of the movie itself some of it
will likely end up being canon including
the existence of utta and uta herself
has already been teased in the manga at
the same time not all aspects of the
movie may necessarily turn out to be
canon for example shiki from strong
world became canon in the manga even
though some events from the movie do not
appear to be and honestly if we really
think about it shanks being a celestial
dragon would explain a lot the fact that
a yonko and one of the most well-known
and notorious pirates in the world was
able to sneak into pangea castle during
the reverie and gain a private audience
with the gorosei seems pretty freaking
unbelievable but if you consider the
possibility that shanks is actually a
member of a prominent celestial dragon
family then this strange situation
suddenly becomes a lot more believable
after all marijuana is the homeland of
the celestial dragons the gorosei
themselves are celestial dragons and if
shanks is one of them then no wonder he
has the knowledge and connections to
infiltrate pangaea castle and gain an
audience with the five elders and for
all we know shanks may have used his
celestial dragon connections many times
before he may have even used these
connections in order to locate and steal
the gomu gomi right under the world
government's nose shanks being a
celestial dragon would change everything
we thought we knew about him and the red
hair pirates and it could also explain
so much about shanks's ultimate goals
and
clearly shanks doesn't agree with the
discriminatory views that most celestial
dragons seem to hold about other people
clearly he doesn't support the world
government because he decided to become
a pirate and clearly he has his own
agenda that doesn't align with the
agenda of the world government but what
is he really up to who is the figureland
family and what role have they played in
the political affairs of marijuana and
the world government at large is shanks
still in contact with some members of
this family and are we going to meet
them eventually what i'm saying is does
shanks have a hot celestial dragon
sister these are all deeply important
questions and they are bound to be
answered soon because the story is in
its final saga let me know down in the
comments whether you accept the theory
that shanks is a celestial dragon and if
it's true how do you think that this
reveal will affect the rest of the plot
oh and if you're on team saint shanks
definitely subscribe for more saint
shanks content in the future
so if shanks was found on god valley as
a baby and if his origins turn out to be
a major twist that involves the
celestial dragons then what about buggy
buggy is the same age as shanks he was
on roger's ship as a young child just
like shanks so does this mean that
buggy's secret origins are also going to
turn out to be a massive twist that is
important to the story i mean i guess he
could end up just being a random orphan
who happened to be the same age as
shanks and who happened to be also taken
in by goldie roger but the far more
likely scenario at least in my mind is
that buggy was also found on god valley
at the same time as shanks i mean i
really doubt that roger is just going
around adopting homeless babies on
multiple separate occasions since they
are the same age buggy could technically
be shanks's twin brother and maybe we
just don't see the resemblance because
of buggy's whole clown aesthetic but i
think that if the two of them were
brothers the roger pirates would have
told them and we would have known that
by now it's more likely that they just
happen to be the same age but then if
that's the case where the buggy come
from i guess it's possible that roger
found him at another location at a
totally different time from shanks but
that would be a pretty big coincidence
roger finds two children on two separate
occasions and takes both of them in like
he's some kind of daycare if these were
just ordinary kids that he met somewhere
along the way it would make a lot more
sense to put him in like a foster home
because that would be a lot safer than
having them living the dangerous lives
of pirates this is why i think that
buggy was found under similar
circumstances as shanks at the very same
location the island of god valley it's
possible that just like shanks buggy
lost his parents on god valley and roger
took him in because he would have died
otherwise but this doesn't mean that
buggy has to be a celestial dragon like
shanks since having both of them be from
completely unrelated celestial dragon
families would be kinda redundant buggy
could have been the child of slaves who
were there on god valley along with the
celestial dragons or he could have been
the child of one of the rock's pirates
perhaps even rox d zebek himself
now this idea that buggy could be the
long-lost son of zebec didn't really
occur to me until i saw it mentioned in
the comments of my other one piece
theory videos over and over again i
guess most of you guys figured out that
i do read the comments and that when i
see comments that contain interesting
theories i end up talking about them in
a future video this must be the case
because i've been getting a lot of well
thought out theories in the comments
lately and i love it and as i said it
turns out that this rox d buggy theory
is actually quite popular in the comment
section so the idea is that zebek had
his one-year-old son with him when he
attacked god valley and once zebek and
his crew were defeated poor buggy was
left on his own roger took pity on him
just like he took pity on baby shanks
and so these two kids were brought
aboard the oro jackson buggy being
zebec's son would definitely explain why
roger couldn't leave him with foster
parents or anything like that the world
government was determined to erase every
single trace of zebic and if they ever
caught wind of buggy's existence they
would have eliminated him without a
second thought in fact buggy's entire
clown attire could have been a
deliberate ploy by roger to conceal
buggy's true identity by disguising him
as a clown maybe without his clown getup
buggy bears a strong resemblance to
zebek and if buggy hadn't disguised
himself the world government may have
caught on the connection between him and
zebek i like this theory because if
bucky was zebek's son then that would
make him a member of the d clan and the
will of d could be partially responsible
for buggy's seemingly unrivaled good
luck i mean this man just keeps failing
upward he literally clowned his way into
becoming a yonko and if it just turns
out that he happens to have an epic
backstory and important lineage i
wouldn't be surprised at all oda has
been hinting at the fact that buggy had
an important part to play in the one
piece story for literally hundreds of
chapters and although he is often used
for comedic relief there has to be
something that explains buggy's insanely
good luck and his continuing relevance
to the story a compelling backstory that
includes a secret connection to zebek
would certainly explain a lot
the issue we have here is that buggy
hasn't really shown any interest in
zebek or the rox pirates while another
character blackbeard seems to be
deliberately following in zebek's
footsteps a ton of people really like
the theory that blackbeard is the
orphaned son of zebec who has been
plotting his revenge against everyone
who brought his father down for 38 years
blackbeard is a year older than buggy
and shanks so he would have been 2 years
old during the god valley incident this
means that blackbeard could also
theoretically be zebek's son
and he could theoretically be buggy's
older brother if there is a secret
connection between buggy and zebek buggy
himself seems oblivious to it and this
could be explained by the age difference
between him and blackbeard if both of
them are the sons of zebec blackbeard is
just about old enough to remember what
happened at god valley or at least some
parts of it while buggy almost certainly
wouldn't remember anything he was only
like one so
unless the roger pirates told buggy
about his true lineage he just wouldn't
know about it meanwhile blackbeard could
still remember the truth and since we
know that he wasn't taken in by the
roger pirates he may have escaped god
valley along with some other members of
the rox pirates and they may have filled
them in on the truth so if this theory
is correct we may see a massive showdown
between two long lost brothers
blackbeard and buggy both of whom are
now emperors of the sea now of course
blackbeard is on paper much stronger
than buggy so if some sort of conflict
goes down between them blackbeard is the
heavy favorite to win but at the same
time you simply cannot count buggy out
the man is extremely crafty and
extremely lucky so you can't
underestimate him personally i'm pretty
confident that the shanks theory is true
and that shanks comes from a prominent
family of celestial dragons as for buggy
his secret origins are far less apparent
but the theory that he might be the son
of zebec and the brother of blackbeard
could make for some interesting family
drama during the final saga of the story
and if it's true that shanks is a
celestial dragon and buggy was the son
of zebek just imagine what roger could
have been planning when he decided to
take both of them in so much of
everything that has come to pass in the
one piece world was planned by roger and
i honestly can't wait to get to laugh
tale and learn the full truth about
roger's master plans
what do you guys think is shanks a
celestial dragon and is buggy the son of
zebec could buggy and blackbeard be
brothers or do you have a better theory
about buggy's secret origins and how he
ended up on roger's ship don't forget to
leave your thoughts down in the comments
below i always love hearing from you if
you enjoyed this video and you want us
to keep it coming with that one piece
content leave a like and comment right
now it helps with the youtube algorithm
and if you haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a big favor and
subscribe right now and also hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications that is a completely free
way of directly supporting the channel
and it means a lot on youtube you can
also hit me up on twitter and instagram
at animeopror as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys